VOICE
This April...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Steven Spielberg invites you to
journey back to a time...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Before every movie was needlessly
converted to 3D.
.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Jurassic Park.
Now needlessly converted to 3D.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Revisit the adventure that launched
your childhood obsession with
dinosaurs...
VOICE (CONT'D)
...and two really disappointing
sequels.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Rexperience the ground-breaking CGI
that still holds up after 20
years...
VOICE (CONT'D)
and the technology that doesn't.
And rewitness... The Goldblum...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Enter a theme park full of live dinosaurs made by impossible science....
Created by John Hammond, a terrible
grandfather who will leave his
grand-kids alone with complete
strangers... and a T-Rex.
VOICE (CONT'D)
When this incredibly dangerous
dinosaur park faces inevitable
insurance problems, Hammond must
finally hire a group of people who
actually know something about
dinosaurs.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Dr. Alan Grant, a brilliant dino
bone scientist - who loves to
traumatize children-
VOICE (CONT'D)
Dr. Ellie Satler, an ancient plant scientist person
And Dr. Ian Malcolm, who...
actually knows nothing about
dinosaurs.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Together, they will experience a
journey through a state of the art
theme park that is fully staffed
and operational...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Except for when it rains.
Stranding them in a deadly zoo
that spared no expense...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Except for tougher fences...
More than one security guard...
VOICE (CONT'D)
An Emergency Power supply...
Sturdier signs...
VOICE (CONT'D)
and paying the one disgruntled
employee who runs the entire park.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Experience in 3D.... The
unforgettable film that'll
constantly remind you... of the
film that you are currently
watching.
VOICE (CONT'D)
The electrifying excitement of
watching a kid in constant peril
who cannot die.
VOICE (CONT'D)
And the unparalleled visual effects
that introduced audiences... to the
GIF
VOICE (CONT'D)
Starring...
Land Jaws
VOICE (CONT'D)
Derp Face
Papa Smurf
VOICE (CONT'D)
BrundleFly
The Olsen Twins.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Two-Eyed Nick Fury
And the guy from Jurassic Park
VOICE (CONT'D)
Jurassic Park. 3D
Oh man what an awesome shot - oh
look at how the banner falls! - I gotta watch this movie again.